l'appel timothée je viens d'île de
france et j'ai 23 ans avant les
compagnons du devoir j'ai fait un bac de
sciences techniques du management et de
la gestion spécialité finances et je
suis à rentrer chez les compagnons du
devoir en 2015 sur un apprentissage en
un an ce qui m'a amené aux métiers d'art
et plus particulièrement au métier de
charpentier
c'est tout d'abord le fait de travailler
à l'extérieur faire un métier derrière
un bureau ça ça m'emballe est pas plus
que ça et mon oncle a beaucoup travaillé
le bois et quand je voyais les
possibilités qu'ils avaient sur ce
matériau ça m'a poussée de plus en plus
à me rapprocher faire le lien entre les
deux et du coup et du coup d'arriver sur
ce métier de charpentier
j'ai connu les compagnons du devoir par
le biais de ma famille qui les
connaissais de réputation et j'y suis
rentré après avoir fait une journée
portes ouvertes chez eux pour entamer un
ca paix en charpente en 2015 et partir
sur le tour de france
par la suite les compagnons du devoir
m'ont apporté tout d'abord un métier un
apprentissage d'un métier et par la
suite la vie chez les compagnons du
devoir a aussi apporté énormément de
choses que ce soit au niveau de la
communauté de la solidarité avec les
autres ce qu'on appelle la fraternité le
fait de voyager aussi m'a permis de voir
beaucoup de choses différentes de
différentes régions lâcher les
charpentes ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes en bord de mer qu'en montagne et
c'est ça m'a apporté en fait une
ouverture d'esprit et non c'est un
développement personnel et culturel
assez important pour moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup dans mon métier c'est qu'on
peut faire énormément de choses
les constructions sont parce qu'un fini
on à dire le matériau du bois et
ce travail comme on veut sinon les
couvrir et voilà le la possibilité en
fait de pouvoir construire une maison
presque entièrement de weylandt faire
une cabane ou encore une charpente de
catena par exemple où c'est vraiment en
fait
un panel de possibilités qui est qui est
énorme sur mon tour de france j'ai
travaillé dans des entreprises de
monuments historiques
on a refait à neuf une église à murat
dans le cantal et c'était en fait tu mon
église avec de la lose donc en fait
c'est une toiture en caire donc la
charpente doit être assez imposante et
du coup on avait des sections de bois
qui allait avec
donc vraiment de la grosse charpente et
c'était c'était un travail assez
titanesque à faire et je vais plutôt
content d'avoir participé puisque sur le
chantier qui a duré un an et demi j'y
suis resté que un mois deux mois
mais voilà il ya ma patte qui est quand
même dessus le projet de la maquette
pédagogique de notre dame est réalisé
par les compagnons du devoir
au niveau national on est quinze jeunes
a participé à faire notre chef-d'oeuvre
pour devenir compagnon sur ce projet là
ce projet est aussi un projet de
formation pour les jeunes qui vont venir
dans la suite voir cette maquette qui
prennent conscience enfin de de cette
charpente qui était notre dame de paris
est aussi un moyen de se souvenir de
cette magnifique charpente qu'on
appelait la forêt c'est un peu un devoir
de mémoire
on se donne je participe à ce projet car
le
département du haut-rhin voulait
s'impliquer sur cette maquette de
formation et j'étais sur mulhouse a
demandé vos compagnons du devoir de
réaliser mon chef-d'oeuvre cet hiver le
billet des deux fait que je me suis
retrouvé à faire ce projet là pour
devenir compagnon
donc mon projet est une partie de la
charpente de notre dame de paris ont
plus particulièrement une travée l'a7
l'a8 du coeur exactement c'est à
l'échelle 1 5e donc c'est cinq fois plus
petit que le réel et ça reste quand même
imposant j'ai commencé ce projet déjà
par revoir en finale toutes les sections
de bois qu'on avait vu que c'était d une
vieille charpente c'était pas forcément
de section carrée et prenez les armes
directement donc on avait une base assez
large en entier plus fine en tête
retrouver exactement la conception de la
charpente trouver les bonnes dimensions
qui aller étape par étape au final
réussir à refaire cette charpente la
difficulté de ce projet ça a été de
retrouver au final la la la forme entre
guillemets réel de cette charpente vu
qu'on avait que des croquis ou
quelques codes donc c'est des distances
et des mesures on n'avait pas
l'entièreté de ces mesures
donc on a dû réfléchir et comprendre en
fait comprendre cette charpente pour
pouvoir reconstruire à neuf
en fait au 1 5e cette charte on l'a
travaillé sur ce projet ça représente
beaucoup de choses je réalise mon
chef-d'oeuvre donc c'est pour devenir
devenir compagnon
c'est la première partie de ce
chef-d'oeuvre après j'en aurai une autre
est aussi ça me rend heureux de
m'impliquer dans le fait de souvenirs de
cette charpente et tout ce groupe de
quinze jeunes qu'on a eu à travailler
sur ce projet là même si on a des des
maquettes différent des difficultés des
choses différentes
ça reste très solidaire et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment super je vais
devenir compagnon du devoir grâce à ce
projet ce qui représente l'aboutissement
d'une partie et le démarrage d'une autre
de ma vie c'est une fierté si j'arrive
au bout de cette aventure fille serait
l'aboutissement de d'un apprentissage
qui a duré plusieurs années sur mon tour
de france et par la suite ça sera mon
tour en tant que compagnon j'aimerais
beaucoup être formateur à mon tour
enseigner le métier qu'on m'a appris à
plus long terme pourquoi pas faire un
tour du monde pour continuer d'apprendre
les différentes charpente conte à
travers le monde et je sais qu'il ya des
charpentes en bout en asie ou des choses
comme ça donc continuer cet
apprentissage de toute une vie quoi